[Music]
so reproductive technologies is sort of
a family of technologies we have in
vitro fertilization where essentially an
egg is being fertilized outside of the
body so that involves harvesting eggs
from women and then implanting a sperm
into that and putting it in there are
some variations on that another very
common form of reproductive technology
is surrogacy in surrogacy and embryo is
being carried by a woman who's not
typically the genetic mother of the
child so another woman is carrying the
egg and sperm combined into a foetus and
then we have a series of other brand new
technologies like mitochondrial
replacement therapy where you're taking
the egg from one woman you're removing
the mitochondria from that egg and
putting in the mitochondria from another
egg to deal with mitochondrial disease
and here there's an idea that there's
actually three genetic parents
there's the genetic father provides the
sperm there's the mitochondria donor and
then there's the woman who donates the
rest of the egg so in reality there's
three genetic parents even though the
mitochondrial donor and only giving a
very small part of the genetic material
in the DNA those are three reproductive
technologies two are very common one is
brand-new and of course the oldest one
that we have is artificial insemination
and in fact this goes back to the 1800s
I believe in the United States at least
and this is essentially what a man
ejaculates his sperm and it's used to
inseminate a woman typically through an
injection although the old things they
say about turkey basters are actually
true you can do at-home insemination
with a turkey baster so those are four
technologies artificial insemination in
vitro fertilization surrogacy and
mitochondrial replacement therapy as a
society there's a series of I would say
traditional and then more novel
challenges posed by these technologies
so the traditional ones involves first
of all how do you get the sperm and egg
is it ethical to purchase sperm and egg
in particular egg where women have to
take hormones women have to go undergo
egg retrieval there's some medical risks
is it ethical or unethical to ask a
woman to donate her egg or just sell her
egg how much can you pay a woman for
that purpose
with sperm there's also in particular a
question of sperm general anonymity in
the United States we allow sperm donors
to be anonymous if they want to be most
sperm donors in the United States are
anonymous many other countries in the
world require individuals to put their
names and identifying information into a
registry available to the child that's
born the donor conceived child at age 18
so the child can try to track down that
person and try to make contact and many
donor conceive children say they have a
right to know
their genetic origins a right to
encounter this person in the US as a
matter of law we don't recognize that
right in terms of surrogacy we really
have two kinds of surrogacy
we have gestational surrogacy where a
woman carries a fetus from the sperm and
egg of other people and traditional
surrogacy where the surrogate is
inseminated by a man's sperm but it's
hooray in traditional surrogacy she's
both the carrier of the baby as well as
the genetic mother in gestational
surrogacy she only carries the baby
there are cases that we have reported
new literature like the famous baby M
case where women who carry babies for
other people become attached to them
they want to have the children as their
own and there is a breakup of the
agreement that was made ahead of time
when the baby is delivered how should we
adjudicate the rights of a surrogate do
we think of a surrogate as just to use a
provocative phrase just an oven just a
cupboard or do we think about that as a
person who is a real mother to the child
and not to have rights there's also a
lot of transnational surrogacy where
people go abroad to use surrogates in
particular to India in part because the
costs are much lower and you have women
serving a surrogate more villages making
for them a lot of money much less than
surrogates making the United States
living in compounds signing contracts
where they can't have an abortion they
get paid by the month and if they
miscarry they get stopped getting paid
and there's questions about whether this
is exploitative of these poor woman or
instead giving them a great economic
opportunity so I would say these all
fall in the bundle of the more
traditional objections of questions the
new technologies we've been talking
about mitochondria replacement therapy
also CRISPR cast nine gene editing which
is a technology we're doing in the lab
but not yet human beings in terms of
reproduction where we edit some of the
genes I'm particularly trying to
eliminate disease-causing genes both of
these raise issues about human
enhancement what should be the limits of
enhancing human beings when do we stop
being human and start becoming post
human is that a problem
are there safety risks involved is it a
problematic for parents to try to
control not only the upbringing of
children but their genetic makeup as
well at what point does it become
oppressive and these technologies pose
really interesting both ethical but also
biological and safety questions of what
the future of humanity might look like
so let me say a word about method how
does one go about analyzing this if
you're new to the field how should we
think about this so I often call the
method going beyond the gut think about
things we think about a case a concrete
case it might be a real case you
encounter for example a story of a woman
in her 60s or 70s in India having her
first child through reproductive
technologies how old mother can be just
for example or could be a fictional case
something from literature like brave new
world or something from films like the
film X Mackinac or the film Gattaca
where we talk about a kind of genetic
arms race and Gattaca among people who
are becoming increasingly perfect and
those who are instead the products of
traditional births so we have a concrete
case that we think about and we have a
gut reaction that's very normal but then
the next thing we have to do is kind of
interrogate where that gut reaction
comes from and it's kind of a top-down
and bottom-up we start with the gut but
then we ask ourselves let me compare
this case to a series of cases that are
like this and some relevant respects but
unlike this in others and ask myself how
do I react to these new cases have added
more items on the board if you will from
those and sorting through my reactions
to new cases our reactions and talking
about it with people we then try to test
out some principles and derive some
principles so we say case a case B Casey
yes case D now and we asked ourselves
what distinguishes those cases we
identify a principal say this is the
principle that distinguishes them and
then we try to apply that as well to a
new set of cases to see whether it's a
good principal does it have to be thrown
out can it be refined okay so that's a
very abstract way of putting it
now let me try to just try and put it in
practice in thinking about human
enhancement and what makes us better so
take the case of trying to enhance
genetically and enhancing intelligence
genetically as an example so imagine we
could make an alteration and we could
either do this and the question be if it
would be different to do it this way
through choosing entirely intelligent
sperm donors and egg donors or actually
manipulating the genome so one question
we'd have to ask ourself is does it
matter which way in which I arrive at
that end and imagine now the goal is to
produce a set of children who will do
better on a test we are wealthy parents
we want our children to succeed
academically people have strong
reactions to that case maybe they think
it's wrong because for controlling these
children's future it's oppressive maybe
they think it's wrong because it has bad
distributive consequences the rich have
a way of perfecting themselves and
getting better the poor do not well now
we want to test it against a very
different kind of case and that's the
kind of SAT tutoring for example there
are test centers across America where
children can get tutored for
standardized tests to improve their
performance tutors for all sorts of
subjects ordinarily most people don't
have a strong negative moral reaction to
the idea of tutoring and the pressure
point to ask yourself is are the
tutoring examples different from the
enhancement examples I've started with
both have the aim of improving the
intelligence of the performance of
children and then we can throw in other
cases performance-enhancing drugs in
sports for example versus the use of
adderall and other drugs to cram for
exams and colleges now we have four
kinds of cases we have doping in sports
you've got college students doing
adderall we've got tutoring and then we
have genetic enhancements so now the
question is we have a pattern of
reactions to these cases can we derive a
set of principles or distinctions that
make a difference and help explain these
intuitions and then also can be used for
new cases in ways that are satisfactory
so kinds of lines might draws the
difference between biological versus non
biological enhancement now all forms of
learning are really biological deep down
but you might think the biological
enhancement of altering the genome looks
different from the biological
enhancement of taking adderall or
cramming for a test or getting tutored
you might also try and draw distinctions
between who's making the decision as to
who will be enhanced in the case of this
sports player or in the case of the
student who's cramming for an exam
there's a lot of self agency the person
is choosing for themselves
in the case of a parent choosing who
will be the sperm or egg donor or
choosing what genetic manipulations to
do to an early embryo you have someone
else imposing the will does that help
explain our intuitions and so on and so
and so forth gets pretty complex you
start drawing charts of distinctions and
thinking about it
but in this form of contestation we can
try to get really to understand what we
really think
[Music]